du S on va revenir ce qui s'est passé
hier soir à Marseille un des candidats
de téléréalité parmi les plus connus un
Greg Yega a été victime d'un vol à Maré
hier soir alors qu'il était en train de
se faire couper les cheveux apparemment
c'est son salon voilà plusieurs
individus armés cagoulé s'en sont pris à
Greg et au personnel du salon il va avec
nous avec nous dans un instant et plus
globalement les célébrités sont de plus
en plus nombreuses à se faire braquer
cambriolé séquestré et Coraline qui
avait été victime d'un homejcking chez
elle sera là aussi puisque on a
l'impression d'être de plus en plus en
insécurité c'est parti
regardez
c'est en 2019 que Greg ya se fait
connaître du grand public en participant
au marseillais moi c'est Greg j'ai 24
ans je suis le meilleur ami de paga très
vite le jeune homme s'impose dans le
programme et devient une star de
téléréalité grâce à son style et son
vocabulaire qui lui sont propres et
bonjour les Bab j'espère que vous allez
tous et toutes bien et alors qu'il
connait une notoriété grandissante Greg
ya qui est suivi par plus de 1,5 million
de personne sur Instagram a subi hier un
fait divers choquant Greg y victime d'un
vol à ma armé puisquil se trouvait dans
un salon de coiffure deux individus s'en
sont pris à lui et lui ont dérobé
plusieurs objets de valeur alors que
s'est-il passé concrètement la star de
télééalité Greg ya victime d'un vol à
armé hier s'exprime en exclusivité dans
tespmp merci d'être avec nous 20h55 on
est en
direct merci Greg d'être là ça va mon
Greg tranquille ben merci pour
l'invitation et ravi d'être là c'est
important merci merci mon gre merci tuas
un amour et puis en plus on va tu vas
nous raconter ton histoire parce que
c'est vrai que ça arrive de plus en plus
plus là il y a Michel Marie lui je
t'explique c'est il est pas là pour
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles on a que
des gens qui rentrent c'est des c'est
des croques morts mon frère merci Michel
en tout cas je suis content de te voir
raconte-nous un peu le le
bail c'était hier soirf
ENF parce que ça va très vite nous
étions donc dimanche et Greg ya était
dans son salon de
coiffure quoi à Marseille d'accord à
Marseille dans le 11e arrondissement de
Marseille c'est ça euh le quartier
saint-marcell c'est ça ben il peut il
peut raconter lui en fait mais puisque
tu m'as demandé de le faire j'étais en
train de le faire maintenant tu
préfères raconter en fait si voulez JEE
ma place hein non je laisse ma place si
vous voulez non mais gre t'inquiète pas
on va faire un duo je n'y tiens
pas gre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé hier
parce qu'on rigole mais bon c'était
quand même non en fait hier hier soir
tout simplement moi je devais monter à
Paris aujourd'hui simplement et c'est
vrai que j'ai ouvert un salon de
coiffure qui s'appelle F Factory qui a
qui est au 106 Saint- Marcel vas-y vas-y
prcom don bring aussi non mais voilà
j'étais en train de j'étais en train de
me faire couper les cheveux
tranquillement avec mon employé et le et
le poteau à mon employé tout simplement
et là j'ai deux individu qui rentre dans
le salon et pour l'anecdote en fait ce
qui est ce qui est ce qui est moi j'ai
senti direct langamb bien arrivé et et
mon employé en fait quand il les a vu
rentrer déjà il leur a dit le salon est
fermé ouais mais quand ils arrivent avec
avec un bon nez une écharpe c'est
compliqué de dire que le salon est fermé
et du coup ils sont arrivés et ben j'ai
rien compris à ce qui s'est passé tout
simplement ils sont direct allé voir mon
employé il y en a un qui a sorti la gaz
Lacrimo ouais l'autre il est arrivé il a
sorti un couteau moi j'ai strictement
rien compris ce qui se passait surtout
que mon salon en plus il y a des caméras
ouais donc c'est filmé et là direct
direct il a pris le poteau à mon employé
donc mon employé s'est fait gazer pour
rien le pote à mon employé il s'est fait
gazer il lui a pris ça saaccroche moi il
est venu directement vers moi avec le
couteau en me disant donne-moi ton Tmax
ah ouais mais moi bien sûr que je ben
tiens prends le Tmax prends-le le T Max
tiens je te le donne je vais pas me
prendre un coup de couteau donc du coup
je lui ai donné le T MAX ou mais en fait
le truc c'est que ben en fait je me suis
protégé moi auparavant et j'ai mis des
des traceurs en fait sur mon sur mon sur
mon Tmax du coup donc du coup il est
parti avec le T Max et en fait c'est ça
qui m'a rassuré dans le sens où c'est
pour ça que je peux en parler maintenant
c'est que je savais où il allait mon
Tmax et je remercie encore la police
parce qu'ils ont fait vraiment un
travail vraiment au top du top
c'est-à-dire que comme ils ont pris le
Tmax en fait je pense que allez 1 heure
après ils les ont interpellé directement
savais qui t' était ou pas pardon savais
qui tu était ou pas du tout je pense que
oui oui pourquoi tu tu t'as senti
comment comment tu l'as senti parce que
je l'ai senti il a été très surpris en
fait tu t'as vu ah ouais ouais ouais
très surpris très en fait j'y vais j'y
vais pas en fait il a été choqué et même
sa réaction elle a été elle a été même
choquée et je pense qu'il s'attendait
pas en fait à me voir tout simplement et
je pense que c'est même pour ça qu'il a
été et ben grâce à ma à ma notoriété on
va dire entre guillemets ben je pense
que peut-être ça m'a sauvé la vie parce
que il m'a pas gazé il m'a rien fait à
moi ouais tu as eu peur il a gazé mon
employé alors que mais je me suis j'ai
eu peur j'ai j'ai vu ma vie défiler
presque parce que s'il me met un coup de
couteau comment je fais moi après ouais
je fais quoi après dans ma vie je fais
rien du tout surtout que je devais
monter aujourd'hui parce que j'avais
j'avais un shooting photo très très
important ouais ça aurait été relou hein
et j'ai pas envie de me prendre moi je
lui donne le T Max après il m'a demandé
les montres tellement j'ai même pas de
monre j'ai plus rien je mets plus de
bijoux je mets je mets rien du tout oui
j'ai mis mon bijou béb
t'è pas voilà mais mais mais du coup non
mais j'ai j'ai voilà j'ai j'ai très peur
voilà j'ai très très peur surtout que en
plus moi je suis un garçon qui aime la
France j'aime la France je suis français
j'aime Marseille j'aime ma ville moi je
suis parti pouri tu trouv tu trouves tu
es plus en sécurité en France c'est pas
après c'est pas moi de dire ça c'est pas
moi de dire si on est en sécurité ou on
est pas en sécurité je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas les les connaissances pour dire ça
si je dirais quelque chose c'est que
peut-être il il manque de
sécurité on est plus en sécurité tu t'es
fait braquer tro fois toi TR fois ouais
tris fois ouis moi j'ai vraiment le
record
franchementau record on
est premier braquage c'est c'était il y
a 3 ans 4 ans cétait avec mon ex
carrément ils sont rentrés chez moi ouis
ils sont rentrés chez moi et tellement
et à l'époque moi j'habitais avec paga
ouais d'accord tu connais très bien je
pense et j'habite avec lui et tellement
que moi dans ma tête je me disais mais
c'est mon collègue qui rentre en fait et
j'ai même pas calculé donc je me suis
remis sur sur l'autre côté sauf que une
minute après ah mais j'ai rien compris
ouais je me suis réveillé j'avais un une
main ganté là et un calibre là ouais
tellement je l'ai regardé mais j'ai
frère carrément c'est GTA GTA carrément
comme comme dans les films comme dans
les films maintenant je peux en parler
parce que ça fait un moment et je suis
content et je suis fier d'en parler pas
je suis fier dans le sens et c'était
quoi la deuxième fois la deuxième fois
si je sortais de chez moi ouais il était
quoi 13h 13h de l'aprè-midi 14h je sors
ouis j'allais chez mon collègue je sors
tranquille de chez moi je fais mes
courses au casino comme comme une
personne lambd en fait je vis parce qu'à
un moment donné peut-être je suis connu
peut-être j'ai la notoriété mais un
moment donné je je veux vivre je suis
pas un robot donc je veux vivre je veux
faire mes courses comme tout le monde
moi j'aime faire ça en fait et le
problème c'est que j'ai pris mon j'ai
pris mon scooter ils m'ont coupé la
route carrément ils sont sortis calibrés
et là ils m'ont demandé
la non non mais non mais ce qu'on disait
mais c'est même pas la question de pas
de chance ou pas c'est qu'à un moment
donné à un moment donné je moi je veux
rester en France sinon la solution c'est
quoi je pars à l'étranger mais le
problème c'est que moi ma ma vie elle
est en France ouais ma vie elle à
Marseille 2e ville de France on a euh
même la France pour moi la France c'est
la France frère pourtant j'ai vécu hein
j'ai vécu hein j'ai vécu à Dubaï je suis
resté 6 mois à Dubaï mais c'est pas
quelque chose qui me PL mais mais
maintenant en en France tu tu tuas tu as
une appréhension quand tu sors quand tu
es ah complètement vraiment ah ouais ah
ouais complètement c'est-à-dire moi
maintenant quand je sors je vois un mec
qui a qui a un casque intégral ou qui a
qui a des gants ou qui a des trucs ou
quoi et ben j'ai peur je regarde je
regarde mon rétro j'essaie de de
d'essayer de de contrôler parce que j'ai
très très peur ouais ouais ouais j'ai
très très peur je suis allé même voir un
psychologue par rapport à ça et M mon
PSI moi il m'avait dit he Clément Luc je
te salue d'ailleurs euh mon PS me
l'avait dit il m'avait dit dans tout
drama essaie de de voir le côté positif
mais quand tu as des trucs comme ça le
côté positif il est compliqué moi je
sais quand ils sont rentrés chez moi
j'arrivais plus à dormir dans ma chambre
je dormais sur le fauteuil sur le
fauteuil de chez moi et je regardais la
porte d'entrée et à chaque bruit en fait
je je levais la tête pour voir s'il y
avait quelqu'un pour voir si si ah c'est
normal c'est c'est moi pour moi c'est tu
dis tu dis qu'il y a beaucoup de stars
de télarité qui partent de France aussi
parce qu'elles sonent plus en en en
sécurité ici je pense que elles partent
parce qu'ils ont ils ont surtout des
enfants je pense aussi
c'est pour je pense aussi pour leurs
enfants ouais quoi ils ont peur pour
leurs enfants je pense aussi qu'ils ont
très très peur pour leurs enfants parce
qu'à un moment donné on vit dans un
monde ok d'accord si on est dans un bon
monde mais moi je trouve qu'on est dans
un monde quand même qui est compliqué
voilà je vais pas après c'est pas moi de
juger mais moi je trouve qu'on est dans
un monde qui est compliqué parce que
parce que moi je fais je fais un métier
la chance j'ai la chance de faire un
métier que j'aime c'est-à-dire moi mon
mon but c'est de divertir les gens
d'amuser les gens euh de faire des
blagues mais quand on a des actions
comme ça j'ai plus envie de rien faire
alors justement